good afternoon
nato allies continue to strong
diplomatic efforts to find a political
solution to the serious crisis
triggered by russia's military buildup
in and around ukraine
despite moscow's claims we have seen
no sign of withdrawal or de-escalation
so far
on the contrary
russia's buildup appears to continue
we continue to monitor developments very
closely
we call on russia to do what it says
and withdraw its forces
from the borders of ukraine
this will be an important first step
towards a peaceful political solution
today we met with our close partners
ukraine and georgia
we addressed the continued threat of
russian aggression
the deteriorating security situation in
the black sea region
and nato's strong political and
practical support for both countries
nato and allies are helping ukraine
boost its ability to defend itself
self-defense is a right
enshrined
in the u.n charter
and allies are helping ukraine to uphold
that right
including with
trainers and military equipment for
ukrainian armed forces
cyber and intelligence expertise and
with significant financial support
we also discussed the presence of
russian forces in the georgian regions
of abkhazia and south ossetia
and the vote of the russian duma
recommending
the recognition of the
non-government-controlled areas of
donetsk and luhansk
we all agree that uh
would be a
further blatant violation of ukraine's
territorial integrity and sovereignty
and of the minsk's agreements
undermining the efforts to find a
political solution in the normandy
format
today allies confirmed that nato's door
remains open
any decision on nato's membership is for
nato allies and aspirant countries to
take
nobody else
the right
of each nation to choose its own path is
absolutely
fundamental for european and
transatlantic security and it must be
respected
nato allies
restated their strong support for the
sovereignty
and territorial integrity
of both georgia and ukraine
we cannot accept a return to an age of
spares or influence
where big powers bully intimidate or
dictate to others
sorry there can be no decisions
about ukraine without ukraine
and no decisions about georgia without
georgia
we agreed that in times of tension
dialogue is even more important
nato remains open to engaging with
russia in good faith
allies are ready to sit down with russia
in the nato-russia council
address a wide range of issues and find
common ground
in the final session our ministerial we
met with our close partners finland
sweden and the european union
we share the same values we face the
same challenges and the crisis in and
around ukraine affects us all
so we agree that it is even more
important now that we continue to work
together
and complement each other's efforts to
bring this crisis to a peaceful solution